why are they doing this what good can
come of this yeah legitimately I know I
I feel the same way dude it's like you
read all these tweets about Bing chatbot
like becoming sentient it's like just
shut it down I'm not concerned about
that I'm concerned about like
misinformation no where they get Joe
Biden to go all right I'm sending a new
nuclear warhead to straight to um
straight to Joe Biden's house or
wait what did you guys do my voice too
can you play it I want to hear it let me
hear a shitty eyes hey this is Ben Khan
the host of trillionaire mindset I like
Diet Coke and uh whatever else I'm into
sounds like you uh it sounds like you
doing me kind of seriously that's what
it sounds like me doing you that would
sound very different trust me yeah it'd
be a lot of giggling for sure
um